what do you think your favorite film
that you've ever been in
is uh music and lyrics with Drew
baramore it is a good film it's the best
film it's very Charming it was huge
those songs in the Far East really
massive like number one is tap we're Big
in Japan yeah we really are or was it
Korea anyway all I think it was all over
the fares big numers I want to do is
find a way back
love perfect apart from maybe the last
note okay now Love Actually is actually
hitting its 20th anniversary and the
girls alowed the band revealed that the
dancing scene actually saved them they
were near Extinction as a band and that
your dance single-handedly revived their
career what do you have to say to
that that's uh well that's something
positive to come out of that experience
I know you hated Dan I know that it's
the morning it's not sexy I know what
it's like my traditional anecdote about
that yes it is true at that age at that
time in my life I I didn't want to dance
especially as you say in the morning do
you really not know and realize that
you're Hugh Grant cuz I don't know who I
am or what my standing is in the world
and now I just get to celebrate people
like you and it's true I mean look at it
the undoing for which you got nominated
needed to not one not two but three
Awards she looks good Nicole looks good
though Nicole always looks good yeah
this is one of my favorite characters
you've ever played well yeah thank you
how nice of you and then you have
Florence Foster Jenkins which you've
also been nominated for several awards
for give me the dirt on
Merl an interesting fact she's she's
great and she's a great actress and she
doesn't like to wear she can't wear
glasses if the part doesn't have glasses
says she won't wear lenses cuz she
thinks the camera can see
them I'm dying a very English
Scandal uh yes well that was good that
was good uh uh what can I tell you about
it another Twisted what's Ben winshaw
like his mother's a therapist so you
know he was brought up with a very
interesting point of view and he's a
lovely man and a genius actor really yes
um he's also the voice of Paddington
yeah so that was weird I had just done
Paddington with him as the voice of
Paddington and then suddenly you know
I'm assaulting him
roughly as one does and Paddington 2
where you met Paul King the direct
swanka was I love when he said that like
Frank cpra was his reference that made
everything make sense to yes I agree
with you he knows all films he's like
you know one of the things that
distinguishes great film directors is
that they know every film in the world
encyclopedic yes and he's like that like
scores like Tarantino proper filmmaker
what film do you think is the closest to
who you are in real life that you've
ever done
Thea I think so too it's like the minute
you walk on screen angry little man I'm
like oh my God this is Hugh this it
literally is you yeah but you have so
much heart so what what do you think is
the film that's the sweetest version of
you yeah well I mean I did all those
sweet roles and I love those films and I
love the fact that people still like
them but I never felt very comfortable
really doing them I I don't know about
you but I prefer more of a mask I want
to be someone else that freeze me up and
I quite like acting well I remember this
moment where people really thought that
I wasn't capable of anything more than a
romantic comedy so I had to show up for
this director I wanted to do this part
in this movie called gray Gardens and he
wouldn't meet with me because he said oh
no she's a romcom girl I want someone
who's won Academy Awards for this yeah
and I beat that guy down until he hired
me and then and you were Mar you think
so no I don't know I haven't seen
[Music]
it